où sont les nouveaux habitants qu'ils
devaient qui devait arriver où sont les
nouveaux commerces
combien ont fermé combien ont ouvert
voilà la réalité les gens le peuvent le
voir tous les jours en se promenant dans
notre ville le souci qu'on a sur nevers
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a un souci de
sécurité au sein du centre ville et de
la périphérie et un souci de propreté
voilà les neuf et reçoit pourquoi ils
délaissent le centre ville
c'est sur une question de sécurité de
propreté et bien sûr d'attractivité de
stationnement comme on a pu en parler
alors qu'on vient voir la quatrième
fleur qui nous réconforte pour la
propreté
je rappelle qu'il ya moins de 300 villes
en france pour la quatrième fleur laisse
aller on savait très bien la verso-s et
avec eux vous verrez si on vous parle
pas on enchaîne